are you guys ready to get kicked in the
emotions well tomorrow is the 77th
birthday of possibly the best known
Christian Republican martial arts turned
internet meme Charles Norris there is
these days
Chuck seen here deciding which audience
member to punch to the screen he spends
his days relaxing on his lone wolf ranch
and selling his new brand of bottled
water see for that's the real thing
Chuck makes his own water by punching
clouds and making nature cry and he for
I got a believe see force is also with
wu-tang name right that feels like
that's probably the thing let's see
which one is me oh they're not us Chuck
will always be the Internet's ultimate
badass with Chuck Norris back detailing
how Chuck Norris once beat a wall at
tennis and Chuck Norris can strangle you
with a cordless phone but at 77 Chuck is
well into old man Logan territory so
comedians I would like you to give me an
old man Chuck Norris fact anyone can
buzz in Matt Braunger Chuck Norris
lowers cholesterol to the ground by
punching in the face yeah pick seven
when he pees it burns through the center
of the earth yes Colton at Chuck
Norrises balls don't get lower as the
ages they get higher it's currently
under his chin you can feedback himself